yeah so now i'm like i'm i'm getting
even more attached to him now obviously
yeah i really want him to tell me
something you know which would indicate
more serious and he was just being very
vague just oh well later we'll we can
talk about it
but like later when why are you asking
me this question ask him ask him
but do you think i have a right to ask
him
i still didn't tell him about living
with my ex
my ex and i we were still together at
the time when things were getting
serious with caliber night we actually
lived together and i hid this fact from
kalib
i didn't tell kylie cause i didn't want
him to back off so i just ended up not
telling him at all
so you think it it should like
be
glued up for like what for what amount
of time i don't know i'm just not brave
enough i don't know how to like start
talking about i can talk to him
you no it's better that it comes from me
yes so get you together and talk to him
i have to come clean to calip about my
past because i don't feel comfortable
pushing him for answers about our future
while i'm still holding on to this
secret
he is a guy who always tries to tell the
truth so i really don't know how he's
gonna react to hearing that i lied to
him
so i'm just hope it's not gonna screw
all the things up
[Music]